ropic how old are you do I look old
hi I'm Mark nice to meet you nice to
meet you so we're switching things up if
I light up red that means you protect
yourself
I'm fine with that all right let's start
this day your two leopards
what brings you Joy my joy
oh [__] he's trying to ask some good
questions brings you because I am not
leaving my kingdom I like that I like
that question what brings you Joy my job
and my family how about you well
definitely not my family or my job
bro why'd you have to admit that right
off the top definitely not my family or
my job what a better way to see somebody
in 10 seconds like my life ain't that
great right now
if she don't hit that button that would
be shocked I think that's the point
you look at the look and you're like you
know what I'm gonna make her buzzer yeah
if I wanted to get somebody I'm like
listen I'm gonna be I'm gonna be [__]
up my [__] crusty you look at the
person and you just be like
the most miserable [__] ever you
just look at her and you'll be like okay
I'm just gonna make her oh let me reject
myself she asks you a question and you
just stare at her and then five seconds
later you just start doing the trumpet
noises
reject this [__] is crazy
my job is just like really depressing
like manual labor no no join that my
family they all just hate each other
Mark has some deal breakers okay is
people who smell bad Justin can he give
you a little whiff
um sure
like
[Music]
I don't know it smells like soap to me
yeah that's not a deal breaker I did
shower today so thank you what are your
thoughts on God do you believe in God
there is most likely no higher power or
at least if there is
whatever higher power
I think that's what it is I think that's
what he's doing he's like I don't know I
don't think so I think this guy might be
one of them social awkward artists
listen me personally no but I support
people
I don't think there's any chance there's
a higher power and I think people who
engage in religion are wasting their
time Jesus
no actually no Jesus
no no no
Jesus
fine Obama
has never kissed a woman or held a
woman's hand you're really helping me
out here bun aren't you it's Jasmine
consensus would you I could hold your
hand yeah I'm okay with that okay like
one hand do you want both hands I think
one one hand's more one hand okay why
haven't you held a woman's hand before
I'm just awful with women man
[Music]
you called her man you call her man I'm
just awful with uh what I told you
before you said you think he's doing it
on purpose no no he's bad with one yeah
that's what I figured it's not something
I've ever been very successful with do
you just get really shy or I I just turn
into a statue okay so this isn't like
making you uncomfortable it really is
okay we could we could stop all right
a woman's hand
thank you for giving me the honor that
still sounds depressing man I'll be
honest
[Music]
thank you for holding my hand and giving
the
now I'm going to take this honor and go
home and never see you again bye not
just the religion thing but also like
the family thing and the job thing I'm a
really big family person I'm very family
oriented so if I were to have children
with someone it would be really
meaningful to me if they got to meet you
know both sides of the family fair
enough yeah but I hope you find someone
that's really great and will also Hold
Your Hand
bye nice to meet you my name is Brittany
ropic how old are you do I look old
I am 31. oh I'm 24. yeah it real quick
how old are you do I look old
you remember when this guy said he don't
like his job and he's not good with his
family
I can see why I feel like this guy
represents what what I think of when I
think of like guys in the YouTube
comment sections we're like look at
these dirty [__] I'm like this is this
guy
never touched a woman not good with his
family takes his job leaves a hundred
comments every day on YouTube and being
super direct yeah I'm 31. oh I'm 24.
yeah I just noticed a little bit of an
age Gap I'm sorry oh you don't look
elderly you're good
[Music]
yo who is this man
social retardation yeah that's crazy
and here's the thing everyone's like oh
yeah he's just about listen you can have
a conversation with someone without
being unnecessarily rude
he don't know you rude
he don't know he rude then somebody's
just smack him upside the head I don't
know how you get to 24 talks like this
to people all the time and not get
punched in the face because his family
left before unnecessary I'm all fine for
telling people the truth you can just
say like listen there's an age God is
fine but all this guy does is just be
rude for no reason I don't think he even
knows yeah people think guys some you
guys think that [__] the [__] oh yeah he
told her what was up it's like you can
tell someone you're not interested
without being a complete jackass you
realize that right no no and now look at
him he's 24 never held a woman's hand
why do you think because
some y'all need to learn how to act
[Music]
I'm on the fence about it
so what is your type you know I don't
have like very much experience to like
really have a type to go after
specifically have you had any serious
relationships not at all no no okay how
do you think you would be as a partner
oh God
yo get this guy the [__] up out of here
get him out of here bro send this dude
home so we can spend his day typing on
Reddit
what would be a deal breaker for you I
don't know uh smoking cigarettes are
like somebody who's Roots away stuff do
you smoke cigarettes I do not I
absolutely hate cigarettes
uh
well I think there was already a problem
because both of us was our age age
ranges are a little bit up and down here
right maybe Mark needs to experience a
woman who's slightly older oh I think
you might need some experience but I
don't think I want to be that person
you seem very nice though oh thank you
yes you're welcome
you have rejected yourself yes would you
explain why
that doesn't feel right I agree I just
want to get out of here yeah bye
this dude looks like he's having a panic
attack
s
they both reach for the button and this
is the second time you touched a woman's
hand
how are you today uh a little hungover
you know that's her party a little bit a
little bit no Spencer looks like he's 12
going on 20. I don't know what's wrong
he got like a little boy's head with a
man's body
look at his head but yeah it's a whole
head
all right he's definitely a costume out
of me how old do you think he is
23.
2012.
stupid
thank you I
think romantic that could happen yes
definitely yeah I disagree
Spencer I'm Elena nice to meet you hi
nice to meet you how old are you 24. how
many years until 2014. guess how old she
is
she look like she probably
27 28. guess how old I am
I'm like [__] I don't know
25. 27.
are things going well I'm enjoying my
time that's all I'm gonna say he said
I'm enjoying my time
that means it's not going well you don't
want to leave
well thanks so much it was great meeting
you by the way
nice to meet you yeah Spencer I'm sorry
okay you're fine can you explain why you
rejected yourself I guess I just feel
more like friendship
yes hello I'm Spencer Spencer Jennifer
nice to meet you nice to meet you you
saw the difference you saw the
difference yeah it even show up our
frame and I saw him change his past yeah
he went hello
I'm Spencer
Jennifer nice to meet you hello tell me
about yourself I do like political
polling for my job gotcha and I'm a
Pianist what do you like to do I like to
run I like uh I love playing tennis
it's really good at guessing people's
astrology signs okay
Sagittarius yeah
yeah let's go
if I'm him I'm just saying yeah to
anything yep
yeah because she feels good and that
means I might get some [__] later so
I've never done that before because are
you a Capricorn I'm like hell yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah when's your birthday I'm
like oh
okay like that's good that's good [__]
Spencer are you into astrology I'm not
like super into it but I know I know my
top three big three you know okay tell
me yeah okay uh Virgo Moon Leo Rising
they kill someone what's up bad
experiences with Leah Leah's are Leos
are a little was that Leo suno or is
that Leo Riser maybe just do the light
rise in your life who knows look at him
swaggy what the [__] is going on here
what was it what is this what is that I
don't really know but I know do you two
think this will happen I am for it but
yeah two-way street
um I think we have like really good
conversations yes but I'm not sure I
could see it progressing right yeah
that's more than friends I'm read that
out I've been here for a second so
nice nice to meet you nice to meet you
Spencer have a good day yes you too
you're lovely human thank you a lovely
human
this girl says when a [__] is
hot she says oh he's hot not a lovely
human well that's a lovely human that's
not something you say when you're
interested but
oh there it is there it is huh what's
your name Jennifer Jennifer nice to meet
you nice to meet you tell me about
yourself well I'm Dominican um prior
military not the crazy kind I know a lot
of people say that but hey what branch
army army yeah okay
tell me about that trust issues I just
feel like people should like come up
with what they want yeah just be upfront
with what you want absolutely just like
leaving someone on do you mind if I ask
if you've like ever been cheated on or
oh it's like no but I'm definitely doing
a lot of cheating
[Laughter]
oh that's what this goes I've been
cheated on okay is that where that stems
from probably maybe okay Michael what
what's up what's a witch [__]
are you super into Zodiacs
a shallow hoes
[__] [__]
back bro I feel like we're fighting back
finally yeah yeah I was Trilogy I mean
I'm not gonna say like oh my gosh this
or that but yeah Leo Leo men are not for
me do you want her to guess what you're
saying there sure like how do you show
emotion
I really don't show it enough emotion I
guess are you a Gemini oh [__] is he a
Gemini no
my man
yeah yeah I'm actually oh my God
yes he went no man [__] I'm still
trying to [__]
no but if you want me to yeah
yeah yeah
come on [__] they tend to have an ego
does it look like I have an ego
no I don't have an ego I'm just like
here's the thing you have an ego she
just took pride in the fact that she can
guess people's signs
what does that mean
okay alchemia
okay yeah
okay here listen here brother
here brother
American
I am just
oh
is that Undertaker no
no I didn't think I was a guy that was
used to go like this you know who I'm
thinking of right now macho man
this guy used to always give me
nightmares who
Goldberg
oh yeah go go no oh go Burger Gold Dust
Gold Dust the one who's he was always
gold and he just told dust Goldberg is
the other dude okay
he was doing no it was not this what he
was doing was this
Who come out of his mouth no no you're
mistaken with Triple H Triple H was
spitting water Gold Dust was this thing
when he was filling himself and then
going like super super zesty that's
zesty as [__]
that was the first trans character we
had he's not a chance he was non-binary
I think you're an attractive dude yeah I
appreciate that yeah are you attracted
to me yeah yeah what the [__]
yeah I already said I'm a Gemini for you
what the [__] you want more that's how I
show my emotions the [__] yeah yeah you
a witch [__] but I love me some [__]
all right
um how would your friends describe you
I'm usually the one that gets everybody
going everybody just calls me like all
right we'll meet Mike ride with me I'm
just like bro I can't split myself into
two people or something okay how about
you how do you friends describe you they
would describe me as very loyal very
honest yeah you know honesty is the best
policy goddamn right would you two go on
the second date each other I'll let her
answer that first no no you can answer
it yeah I would I would
all right I'm gonna light up red one
last time if you don't press me you'll
win this just really shows you that
attracts and Trump's everything because
this man called her a witch [__] and
she was like he's hot whatever
that's what just happened in front of
everybody right here
yeah
oh [__] what do you like to eat no no no
you can plan this oh [__] initiative
initiative okay all right I got you red
button
I actually could follow this oh you like
to cook I love that
[Laughter]
all right all right that was it for
today's all right what do you think that
was what it was yeah that was what it
was rejecting yourself is definitely
something different
you know there's some people that just
next next
when you're able to reject yourself you
try that thing and then after that
you're like yeah no no it was definitely
better than the other episode so what do
you guys think did you guys enjoy
today's episode let us know